again he knows his lane right to the
hole
Bob reddish over to Collins delegates
come away
Lanza want the bounce holiday Gibbon go
to Zion
[Applause]
the kicks it out the corner both teams
played on Monday on their first
preseason game good defense from holiday
ball knocked away and stolen by
Williamson finds holidays honor in ski
in pursuit nice holidays defense
initially is what really helped
Williamson get that steep holiday the
great on sunfish play right there by
ball in the open floor is just beautiful
to see mainly because he runs some stuff
to free the people to stores and the
editions now with white and cornet and
then young that's three big additions
for your second unit and even score if
you're not a play the way they want to
play and that is less here they were
third in the ligand spline he seems to
be in the right place knows really open
first very good there is nice move
without the ball
see he's easy if his man hesitates and
steps away from him to look to help out
on a dribbler
he's moving without the ball quickly on
the deflection belly Honea top of the
shot clock on his way
picked up by Sullivan Hill my rant
against Harrison
see he gets to the left hand and it is
over Wham
[Applause]
against my rants
[Applause]
one of the best players on the planet
against a rookie and a rookie meets the
moment he does it he stays down doesn't
jump put a head fake and then is able to
use his size and length to come up with
a huge block on Kyrie reverie almost
forgotten it could have got the ball and
call the timeout Houston box of Senators
Valanciunas machinery Brandon Clark
make people fill any other way with this
to hand-finished here I'll be ball PJ
Tucker and yes that is your starting
point guard for the Memphis Grizzlies
watch the young fella here go behind
your back
split the to fake the defender takeaway
finish this off off the glass of
something knows no words it's just a
cellar with the foul Marant can't
convert the three-point play
[Applause]
whose near towards the end playing on
this one there's not a struggle it's
just about athleticism strength and the
wherewithal to finish amongst three torn
as defenders love to go left love to
finish with that left hands able to
squeeze through Zeller and get the left
hand finished no time left on the clock
there is neither play D but what a
fantastic finished on a young fella
amongst the trees
well JA 11th in the league and fourth
quarter scoring comes out to Anderson
here is Moran turning on the burgers and
the back moves around
just watch where he starts it that
starts at the free throw line into the
Chippewa down to six Moran trying to
shake free from Beverly chuck got down
to three a deep three Moran
[Applause]
Morant with the shot clock winding down
over patrick beverley one step in front
of the bear 24 mitchell 27-foot bucks
out of it she valanciunas sleep the
Grizzlies with 22
[Applause]
I'll call it there with the reaching in
[Applause]
so Utah's over the limit so there still
will be free throws as high as 33
against Milwaukee Moran's down the lane
and powers it in Gobert did not
challenge and it's a three-point game I
mean watch this this is with 40 seconds
to go in a tight game crosses them going
away from the basket throws it in
changes when he is retreating
defensively can't go far too far into
the paint because they never play the
biggest diamond gets his offense going
early and it is a function of how many
times he drives to the rim but JA gets a
lot of heat shot SWAT nifty move there
that's not gonna get bla
ankle sprain here's Walton his three
[ __ ] knowin the rebound to
Valanciunas so patrick beverley is out
with the right wrist brain called
JA Marant think is he's already playing
up and the thing about these wing
players and what's so good
but this Grizzlies team this year is it
always had to be Mike Conley to had to
bring the ball up every time look at the
catch they aren't and finished here to
the second floor Solomon Hill off the
pump fake Iran with a pump fake Oh
better hit down Oh whoopsie Oh
Robinson handle losing just not gonna
save this way and whoa whoa whoops
whoops where'd he go where'd he go let
me compose myself and then knock you
down he had to come up with it he had to
compose himself first cuz after you make
the move it's like okay that did happen
and he's not gonna get back
[Applause]
and he did that in the face of all stop
great hustle great anticipation by Moran
and then just create when he built he
jumps here it's like whoa let me see
what I'll get that I'll turn around
creating
[Applause]
really love playing with one another and
they play together in such a nice
fashion we always talk about Moran what
will he do will partner there's a lot
five straight rookie moving forward the
ability to stretch the defense we
already know I think Nico Mele is
feminine form right here air sign for
tween now he goes up and gets the
basketball in Zion gives it up gets it
back serious again point land so right
now it's got 18 points in seven of ten
shooting alpha he's really gifted 41st
overall Tim Conley
whoa man Brooks again see Dylan step
backs gun
[Applause]
Phoenix marette now is 78 in the quarter
[Applause]
come get some of this into the middle
look before you better go get he said a
good screen on offense
[Applause]
Williamson look at this though see he
came all the way from Donna left-wing to
get that ball he has such confidence
that he can out-jump anyone Clark
covered it by Porter five to shoot
Moran works against Craig on the face
[Applause]
the Michael Malone was arguing for an
offensive foul Vonzell ball with 8 on
the shot clock
so rackets start offensive ly ok listen
do you have member I say this all the
time he is one of the world they have
retooled nicely you lose the hands knees
Davis you can't do better than what they
were able to put together
Valanciunas is ok in this Parliament if
he didn't come down his hands but how
about that throw fin look we catch the
ball this is the balls nowhere near the
best look and it's a lob from midcourt
look at that there's Westbrook from the
foul line can't get it and rebounded by
ball who is averaging about six boards
per game it's the rim and the entire
stanchion is still moving saturon ski
you know he's going
transition day
Marie timing great timing Lonzo did his
job by staying in front of Saturn ski-in
forcing him to adjust Moran find the
shoes job got caught in the air shot
clock down to two desperation three I
give you a 26 footer the prisons haven't
been a three-point shooting team all
night but I'm saying this much this
young fella is a winner through and
through he only knows how to play
winning basketball and because of that
this grizzly team is in the playoff hunt
right now Moran he has two of the
Grizzlies five triples to mantle
intruder almost threw it away Nader
knows clock is down don't stop the
denial then AB donator is gonna have to
make Zion pay at this end that's gonna
be tough six tenths of a second enough
time to catch it and shoot guys have a
great year Brandon Clark
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Bob the rims the man many he came to
seeing up top for Zion
Simeon legacy that carries on in
Kendrick
Williamson from his AAU team a job look
at this bad let's see here
this is the fools are raining down to
the Windy City right now
[Applause]
just look at the what's more it goes to
Zion judge our ducks in pictures up you
got Zion Duncan is these picking poison
on that what it's hand them right there
hit me I'll start we come out here just
beat everybody around the league and the
two headliners goodness gracious I'm
making some highlight just snuck it over
the rim
[Music]
small 360 action you know couple guy job
a rant with a smooth 360 finish don't
try that at home ladies what foot
working side on Eric Pascal another
rookie rule its take it away he thought
he was yet now Zion on the moon look at
great pass one so gets it to get
everything out of everybody but also he
just signed a 10-day just a few hours
ago so the Warriors want to take every
chance they can get you evaluated
got the triple
is dead form on the three again you see
the advancement of the basketball pool
Tori oh hey whoa whoa whoa hold on hold
on that's a nice shot put
trying to get Valanciunas flashing in
the post Moran
[Music]
Jung's trying to get him going got to
make sure we show our hands what he's
got the ball
[Applause]
rooks is out with the four files Josh
Jackson in and delivers a beautifully
stolen by George McCrory throws it and
they tell you as a guard to always throw
it to the corner of the backboard got to
go into the shot clock I guess that's
high percentage favors staying with it
but that's to looks at the Pels good and
tap at home tough break what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content